hey youtubers it's Charlie this is going
to be my arrow episode of 20 video
careful for spoilers if you haven't seen
it yet I'll also talk about Deathstroke
on the Teen Titans TV shows it's going
to be happening next year there's a new
round of the flash ring giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
leave a comment on this video so what
I'm going to do is I'm going to start
with the arrow stuff obviously and then
I'll talk about Teen Titans Deathstroke
stuff a lot of you had questions about
how connected Titans is going to be to
the arrow verse so Geoff Johns has
actually confirmed a few things so I'll
explain that at the end of the video but
this episode was mostly like a scorched
earth policy of getting Prometheus all
about Prometheus hunt that's the way I'm
thinking about these last four episodes
in the show runners have teased that a
bunch of people are going to die in that
finale so we can talk about that as we
get a little bit closer to but the title
of the episode Dangerous Liaisons is an
easter egg for the movie which is a
period piece about how like a good
person
tries to get revenge for a slight that's
done against her but winds up becoming a
villain by the end of the story through
her own actions and it just ends
terribly for everyone so everybody ends
up at odds with everyone else and that
was kind of what was happening in the
episode so there was a lot of a low
level friend on friend violence and a
whole bunch of shout outs for Argus
Suicide Squad stuff so number 10 the
arcade intro I totally love the maximum
force out zone Easter eggs it has been
so long since I've set foot in an actual
arcade dave and buster's is a pretty fun
place to go for arcade machines mister
terrific tells them be careful these are
vintage in some how Prometheus finds a
way to hack himself into that last one -
just kind of waving at them by game over
is that very identifiable video game
sound plays
[Music]
the father guys so number nine they deal
with the fallout in the mayor's office
so this is actually a really big deal
they brush over it relatively quickly
but but Oliver has to answer to all the
families of the victims that Promethea
is killed but then at the same time you
have to remember that Prometheus Adrian
chase was the prosecutor so they're
going to have to wind up releasing all
the criminals that he prosecuted so the
funny thing about that is that
Prometheus wasn't all bad Adrian chase
was actually pretty good at his job as
an attorney so he put away a lot of bad
criminals that are now going to be
dumped on the street simultaneously so
there's a tidal wave of terrible people
that are getting ready to hit the
streets and team arrow is going to have
to deal with that but number eight they
sort of tee up wild dogs story line with
his daughter which I love the way they
ended the episode there were a lot of
really big downer moments because it
seems like Diggle might be getting
divorced it seems like Felicity is at
odds with team arrow the one hopeful
thing in the episode is Wild Dogs
daughter so they kind of explain why it
is that he hasn't visited her this whole
time he just thinks he's complete
garbage he was in a bad place but the
really cool thing is that the wild dog
character has already been confirmed is
a season six regular meaning he's going
to be in most of the episodes so you can
see the goal by the end of the season
for his character is in putting his
family back together what's left of his
family because his wife is dead so he
just has his daughter so that's sort of
a metaphor for the larger team arrow
Oliver
making the family of team arrow come
together again by the end of the season
sort of fixing all their own problems
and if you want to be hopeful about
Diggle and Lyla you could say the same
for them too so number six Felicity's
friend totally kills the double agents
it's been working with Prometheus inside
Argus and you start this domino effect
of friends turning on friends in
everybody's relationships just eating
each other alive so you have Felicity at
odds with helix at odds with team arrow
you have Diggle at odds with Lyla it all
starts because of the helix person that
Argus is holding illegally Amanda Waller
style so we'll talk about Amanda Waller
Suicide Squad stuff too because Argus is
also holding black siren who showed up
in the trailer that they released and
she was very free so Argus is a big part
of the back half of the season and
remember they also operate the prison on
the island where there
holding Deathstroke so number 5 Felicity
suiting up to go into the field so this
is played a little bit for comedy
because she's not threatening at all
unless she's hacking someone and they
have this really funny moment where
they're all assembling and they're like
hey we could invade Russia with all this
gear just making you remember all the
Russia storyline that we've had this
season with the Bratva
they are totally going to come back
remember KGB's and Oliver did not leave
on good terms so I'm kind of hoping that
they bring them back as villains in
season 6 because they're not going
anywhere
David Nichol is a great actor he'll
always come back to arrow whenever he's
available but you kind of start to see
where things go from bad to worse when
they start passing out guns and it's
like oh yeah yeah very clearly something
really bad is going to happen and I
really like the conversation that
Felicity has with Oliver where she's
kind of doing the exact same thing that
he did like he tries to tell her look
the reason that Prometheus exists is
because of the way that I went about
trying to clean up the city you're doing
the exact same thing so he's trying to
warn her that even though they might get
prometheus
she might wind up causing some giant
collateral damage situation which is
kind of what's happening on the flash
this season very trying to do good
things but as a result he creates things
like flashpoint saboteur becomes a big
villain so it's all a side effect of
Barry derping and Felicity is making the
same mistakes now number four though is
the black side invasion so it was really
cool action set piece where they all
roll in they have that big moment where
Felicity puts the barrier up and it's
more of like a visual way to tell you
how she is at odds with Oliver but they
also tease that other people are being
held at that black site and it's so
hardcore they're like hey who would they
need to keep here it's this bad so
you're like wait a minute are they
keeping black siren here are they
keeping King shark here where are they
keeping all those metas locked up but if
we do get a Suicide Squad episode in the
future I do kind of hope that they use
that old set that they use for the
Suicide Squad stuff back during season 2
just as a visual reference to that like
oh my god here we go again so number
three is Lila turning into a new version
of Amanda Waller
I love the possibilities because even
though they're bringing Deathstroke back
there's an argument that a lot of movie
characters might be off limits
I think Amanda Waller might be one of
them because there's an oscar-winning
actress playing Amanda Waller in the DC
EU in the actors the
is Amanda Waller on arrow is on another
TV show with the patty spivot actress
which is kind of a funny coincidence I
think that was the reason for killing
the character off so if we see Amanda
Waller again it'd have to be from some
other different earth and be an easter
egg but because you don't have her to be
the villain of this story they're slowly
turning Lila into that character without
completely throwing her under the bus
like I don't think she'll ever be quite
as hardcore as Amanda Waller if you
remember the Russia episode where Oliver
was torturing that guy and cagey beast
walks down and goes oh my god what
horror is this what are you doing to
this man in Oliver says oh it only took
me a couple minutes to break him the
rest of the time was just spent
practicing he said that his friend
taught him how to torture people that
friend was Amanda Waller during the
season three flashbacks
so Amanda Waller taught Oliver how to be
this crazy torture machine so I don't
think that Lyla will ever be that bad
but number two
Felicity gets kicked out of helix and
for a minute I do kind of wonder if
she's going to be on her own for a while
but then they bring her right back to
team arrow and you get that big twist we
find Adrian chase but he's here oh my
god and then BOOM everything blows up in
their face so number one the EMP turned
this into trapped in an arrow cave next
week so there's two ways of looking at
this one it was Adrian chase that
planted that EMP but to the larger
implication is that the helix people set
that up and they wanted to destroy team
arrows arrow cave so they couldn't then
turn right back around and recapture
that helix leader that they just freed
so let me know about where you think the
season is headed and just to talk about
Deathstroke Teen Titans crossover so
actually just to be clear the show is
called Titans it is being written by
Geoff Johns
he's already confirmed that Beast Boy
and I believe Starfire are going to be
on the team but the big question I know
everyone's asking is is how much will we
see the arrowverse crossover Deathstroke
is the best example of that because he's
way more of a Teen Titans character than
he is an arrow character or really
anybody else's comic book most of that
storyline takes place through his
children who have all been members of
the Teen Titans at various points
Jericho was a member of the Teen Titans
Grant Wilson tried to kill most of the
Teen Titans in rows Wilson his daughter
was a member of the team for a while so
great Wilson is the first version of
Ravager
I think they'll save that character for
Titans TV show he be a perfect fit and
you can't do grant willson Ravager
without doing his father Deathstroke at
some point so this is a little bit of
speculation but I think just to keep it
easy for the writers and not make things
too crazy is that they'll do a Supergirl
thing where they just put it in a
different universe just use multiverse
theory to connect Titans
to the other arrowverse shows so it can
be connected and you can have Manu
Bennett play Deathstroke if he wants to
or if they want they can recast another
version of the character and they don't
have to deal with it every single day on
the other arrowverse shows that are on
the same earth like arrow in the flash
so what will probably happen is that
they'll start talking more about what's
going on with the show as we get closer
to the summer it's still very early
stages in Geoff Johns isn't the only
person writing it but he's probably
going to be one of the people to talk
about it most just because he's such a
big figurehead and if you want to read
good Teen Titans stories obviously Judas
contract is a good place to start but
Geoff Johns actually wrote a version of
the comic book now it was Teen Titans it
wasn't Titans so if you've never read it
before and you want to start somewhere
then you can actually just start with
Titans rebirth it's actually a great
comic book but Deathstroke is such a big
character for that group of people that
there is no way they can do that series
without bringing him on at some point
even if he's not the main villain but he
would be a perfect big bad for one or
two seasons but it depends on how crazy
they're going to get and I think they're
going to get pretty crazy so there's so
much stuff going on with the flash I'm
actually going to be doing a flash
button video in the next day or two that
might be my next video there's some new
spider-man home coming and I'll do some
new flash avatar stuff this weekend too
so all kinds of DC comics and Marvel
stuff happening so congratulations to
the latest giveaway winner Willy
Rodriguez please private message me so I
can get your contact details you can
click here for the brand new flash
trailer and you can click here for my
flash episode thank you so much for
watching let's high-five I'll see you
guys in the next video